القاضي الذي سيمثل امامه ترامب في قضيه
الوثائق السريه بعد ساعات قليله هي امراه
عينها قبل ثلاثه اعوام فمن هي هذه السيده
ايلين كانون عمرها 42 عاما امريكيه من اصل
كولومبي تخرجت عام 2007 من كليه الحقوق
بجامعه وعينت في المنصب بعد 12 عاما من
قبولها لاول مره لممارسه القانون وهو الحد
الادنى من الخبره التي تقول نقابه
المحامين الامريكيه انه يجب ان يتمتع بها
المرشحون في القضاء الفيدرالي ستتراس
المراحل الاولى من مثول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق امام المحكمه الفيدراليه جنوب
فلوريدا في واحده من اكثر القضايا
القانونيه المهمه في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده اذ لم يواجه اي رئيسنا امريكي
السابق اتهامات فيدراليه كانون كانت اتفقت
مع فريق دفاع ترامب انه لا ينبغي لمكتب
التحقيقات
مراجعه الوثائق التي عثر عليها في منزله
الصيف الماضي حتى يقوم طرف ثالث مستقل
بفحصها لكن محكمه استئناف الغت لاحقا قرار
كان وانحازت الى وزاره العدل فالمحكمه
تعتبرت ان كان تفتقر الى سلطه لتعيين شخص
او جهه لمراجعه الوثائق فيما تتضمن لائحه
الاتهام الجديده 37 تهمه بينها التامر
لعرقله العداله برايكم هل سيكون وجود
كانون في القضيه لمصلحه ترامب ام لا